selamat kembali ke kursus Memahami Maklumat dan Pengiraan Kuantum nama saya John Watrous dan saya ialah pengarah teknikal untuk pendidikan
di IBM Quantum ini ialah pelajaran ke-9 dalam siri ini dan merupakan pelajaran pertama dalam unit ketiga yang membincangkan formulasi
umum maklumat kuantum sehinggalah kini kita telah menggunakan formulasi ringkas maklumat kuantum
di mana keadaan kuantum diwakili oleh vektor kompleks yang mempunyai Norma Euclidean sama dengan
satu sebaliknya dalam formulasi umum maklumat kuantum keadaan kuantum diwakili oleh
matriks jenis tertentu yang dikenali sebagai matriks ketumpatan pelajaran pertama unit ini memberi tumpuan khusus kepada matriks ketumpatan
dan kita akan pelajari apakah ia dan cara ia berfungsi semasa pelajaran ini berlangsung matriks ketumpatan sangat
berguna dan ia menawarkan pelbagai kelebihan yang akan kita bincangkan ia membolehkan kita mewakili
kelas keadaan yang lebih luas berbanding vektor keadaan kuantum termasuk keadaan sistem yang telah terjejas oleh hingar misalnya serta
pilihan rawak bagi keadaan kuantum kita juga akan meneliti sfera Bloch yang memberi kita cara
geometri yang sangat bagus dan mudah untuk berfikir tentang keadaan qubit dan kita akan lihat bagaimana ia berkait dengan matriks ketumpatan dengan cara yang
agak luar biasa melalui matriks Pauli akhirnya kita akan bincangkan matriks ketumpatan dalam konteks pelbagai
sistem dan khususnya kita akan lihat bagaimana ia membolehkan kita menerangkan keadaan kuantum bagi sistem yang dilihat secara terpencil walaupun
ia berkorelasi dengan sistem lain dan itu termasuk kemungkinan ia terbelit dengan sistem lain ini adalah perkara penting untuk
boleh dilakukan dan ia tidak mudah dilakukan dalam formulasi ringkas maklumat kuantum berikut ialah gambaran keseluruhan pelajaran ini
kita akan mulakan dengan asas matriks ketumpatan termasuk definisi yang berkaitan dan beberapa contoh dan kita juga akan
bincangkan bagaimana ia berkait dengan vektor keadaan kuantum kita kemudian akan membincangkan kombinasi cembung matriks ketumpatan atau dalam
erti kata lain apa yang berlaku apabila kita mengambil purata berwajaran bagi matriks ketumpatan kita akan mulakan dengan contoh
spesifik iaitu keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya kita akan lihat bagaimana keadaan kebarangkalian klasik boleh dilihat sebagai
kes khas matriks ketumpatan dan kita akan bincangkan bagaimana teorem spektral dari aljabar linear memainkan peranan dalam
konteks ini bahagian ketiga pelajaran ini adalah tentang sfera Bloch yang menyediakan cara geometri untuk melihat keadaan
qubit tunggal seperti yang saya sebut di awal pelajaran ini dan dalam bahagian keempat pelajaran kita akan bincangkan bagaimana matriks ketumpatan berfungsi untuk pelbagai
sistem kita akan bincangkan keadaan hasil dan keadaan berkorelasi pelbagai jenis termasuk keadaan terbelit serta
konsep keadaan terkurang iaitu penerangan matriks ketumpatan tentang keadaan bahagian terpencil suatu sistem majmuk
yang boleh dikira menggunakan operasi yang dikenali sebagai Surih Separa sebelum kita masuk ke kandungan teknikal pelajaran ini ada
baiknya kita luangkan beberapa minit untuk memberi motivasi penggunaan matriks ketumpatan menggunakan formulasi ringkas
maklumat kuantum yang tidak melibatkan matriks ketumpatan kita dapat menerangkan algoritma kuantum seperti
algoritma pemfaktoran Shor misalnya tanpa sebarang kesulitan jadi kenapa kita perlu ambil pusing tentang matriks ketumpatan
atau formulasi umum maklumat kuantum ini langsung eh ada beberapa sebab pertama matriks ketumpatan
mewakili kelas keadaan kuantum yang lebih luas berbanding vektor keadaan kuantum termasuk keadaan kuantum di mana kita ada ketidaktentuan atau
kerawakan ini penting apabila kita nak modelkan kesan hingar ke atas pengiraan kuantum misalnya
kedua menggunakan matriks ketumpatan kita boleh menerangkan keadaan kuantum bahagian terpencil sistem majmuk seperti
keadaan sistem yang terbelit dengan sistem lain yang mungkin buat sementara waktu kita pilih untuk abaikan seperti yang saya sebutkan di awal
pelajaran ini ini tidak mudah atau secara semulajadi dilakukan dalam formulasi ringkas maklumat kuantum
sebab ketiga ialah apabila kita menggunakan matriks ketumpatan maklumat klasik sebenarnya muncul sebagai
kes khas jadi bukannya ada analogi antara keadaan kebarangkalian dan operasi pada
satu pihak dan vektor keadaan kuantum serta operasi uniter di pihak yang lain kita ada maklumat kuantum dan klasik
yang diterangkan bersama dalam satu rangka kerja matematik yang merupakan perkara yang penting dalam kajian matematik
maklumat kuantum jadi kalau kau serius nak faham maklumat kuantum pada tahap matematik adalah sangat
disyorkan supaya kau belajar tentang matriks ketumpatan jom kita mulakan dengan definisi matriks
ketumpatan untuk keperluan definisi itu katakan X ialah suatu sistem dan sigma ialah set keadaan klasiknya dan ingat bahawa
apabila kita menggunakan istilah tersebut andaian kita ialah Sigma adalah terhingga dan tidak kosong dan seperti biasa kita boleh pilih
nama yang berbeza jika kita mahu matriks ketumpatan yang menerangkan keadaan sistem X ialah matriks yang mempunyai
entri nombor kompleks yang baris dan lajurnya telah dipadankan dengan set keadaan klasiknya dan untuk jelaskan
padanan itu adalah sama untuk baris dan lajur secara serentak ini bermakna matriks ketumpatan
sentiasa matriks segiempat sama dan selain daripada segiempat sama ada beberapa syarat yang perlu
dipenuhi dan kita akan bincangkannya tidak lama lagi orang selalu menggunakan huruf Greek huruf kecil tertentu untuk menamakan matriks
ketumpatan rho selalunya pilihan pertama dan pilihan biasa lain termasuk Sigma huruf kecil dan tao yang ditunjukkan pada
skrin ini hanyalah konvensyen tetapi seperti biasa jenis konvensyen ini membantu kerana ia menjadikan benda lebih
mudah dikenali dan sekarang jom kita bincangkan syarat atau keperluan yang perlu dipenuhi oleh matriks ketumpatan untuk menjadi
matriks ketumpatan yang sah ada dua syaratnya dan apa yang akan saya lakukan ialah menyenaraikannya dahulu
kemudian baru saya bincangkan dengan lebih terperinci apa maksudnya syarat pertama ialah matriks
ketumpatan mesti mempunyai surih unit atau dalam erti kata lain Surih sama dengan satu dan syarat kedua ialah
matriks ketumpatan mesti separa positif definitif dan dalam kedua-dua kes kita ada cara simbolik yang ringkas untuk menyatakan
dua syarat ini yang muncul di skrin sekarang biar saya bincangkan dua syarat ini dengan lebih terperinci
syarat pertama merujuk kepada surih iaitu fungsi yang sangat penting yang ditakrifkan untuk semua matriks segiempat sama
dan ia hanyalah jumlah entri pepenjuru dan berikut ialah persamaan yang menyatakan itu
secara eksplisit sekarang ada banyak yang boleh dikatakan tentang surih dan mengapa ia penting tetapi buat masa ini mari kita perhatikan sahaja
satu sifat paling asasnya iaitu ia adalah fungsi linear sifat lain bagi surih akan muncul dan kita akan bincangkannya apabila
perlu tetapi untuk kekalkan tumpuan kita pada matriks ketumpatan jom kita beralih ke keperluan kedua dan keperluan itu ialah
matriks ketumpatan adalah separa positif definitif ini juga merupakan konsep penting yang timbul dalam banyak keadaan dalam
WEBVTT
fizik kimia pengoptimuman pembelajaran mesin dan bidang lain dan ia boleh dinyatakan dalam beberapa cara berbeza tetapi
setara satu cara untuk menyatakannya ialah kata suatu matriks rho adalah separa positif definitif jika wujud matriks M
sedemikian rupa rho sama dengan M dagger kali M dan rupa-rupanya tidak kira sama ada kita minta M itu sendiri adalah matriks
segiempat sama atau kita lepaskan syarat itu cara lain untuk menyatakan apa maksudnya matriks rho adalah separa positif
definitif ialah kata rho adalah Hermitian yang bermakna ia sama dengan transpos konjugat sendirinya dan semua
nilai eigen-nya adalah nombor nyata bukan negatif secara umum matriks Hermitian hanya boleh
mempunyai nilai eigen nombor nyata tetapi boleh jadi negatif tetapi jika kita tambah syarat tambahan bahawa tiada
nilai eigen yang boleh jadi negatif kita dapat matriks separa positif definitif dan by the way kalau kau diberi
satu matriks dan nak tahu sama ada ia separa positif definitif kau boleh tentukan itu menggunakan pencirian ini adalah agak mudah untuk
semak sama ada matriks itu Hermitian atau tidak perkara itu boleh dilihat dengan sekali pandang ia lebih sukar untuk mengira
nilai eigen tetapi ia bukan sesuatu yang terlalu sukar untuk dilakukan dengan komputer kerana ada algoritma yang sangat cekap untuk melakukannya
dan pencirian terakhir yang akan saya sebut walaupun ada yang lain ialah untuk setiap vektor lajur s yang mempunyai
bilangan entri yang sepadan dengan bilangan baris dan bilangan lajur rho ketaksamaan yang ditunjukkan pada
skrin adalah benar dalam kata-kata bra s kali rho kali ket s mesti nombor nyata bukan negatif
tidak jelas by the way bahawa pencirian-pencirian ini semua setara tetapi memang begitu dan biar saya nyatakan secara eksplisit bahawa
notasi yang biasa kita gunakan untuk menunjukkan matriks rho adalah separa positif definitif kelihatan seperti rho adalah lebih besar
daripada atau sama dengan sifar tetapi ini hanyalah notasi ringkas dan ia tidak bermakna secara literal bahawa rho adalah lebih besar daripada
atau sama dengan sifar rho adalah matriks jadi itu takkan masuk akal dan ia tidak bermakna
bahawa setiap entri rho adalah lebih besar daripada atau sama dengan sifar khususnya ada matriks
separa positif definitif yang entri-entrinya tidak semua bukan negatif dan ada matriks yang entri-entrinya semua bukan
negatif tetapi ia bukan separa positif definitif idea di sebalik notasi ini ialah matriks separa positif definitif
adalah seperti analog matriks bagi nombor nyata bukan negatif tetapi ini hanyalah notasi dan maksudnya ialah
tepat seperti yang telah kita bincangkan sekarang jom kita tengok beberapa contoh mulai dengan contoh matriks
separa positif definitif sebenarnya ia agak mudah untuk menghasilkan contoh rawak matriks
separa positif definitif dengan hanya memilih matriks M secara sewenang-wenangnya dan kemudian mengira M dagger kali
M misalnya berikut ialah matriks M yang tidak terlalu istimewa dan sebenarnya saya
menghasilkan matriks ini secara rawak dengan memilih secara bebas bahagian nyata dan khayalan entri-entrinya sebagai integer antara negatif 9 dan positif
9 jadi sebarang corak atau struktur di sini adalah kebetulan semata-mata dengan mendarab
transpos konjugat M dengan M kita dapat matriks ini yang oleh itu adalah separa positif
definitif tentu saja ada had berapa banyak pemahaman yang boleh kita perolehi daripada contoh rawak tetapi ia memang menunjukkan beberapa
ciri yang biasa bagi matriks separa positif definitif secara amnya khususnya kau akan perasan
bahawa entri pepenjuru iaitu yang berada di sepanjang garisan dari kiri atas ke kanan bawah semuanya adalah nombor nyata bukan negatif
dan tambahan pula entri luar pepenjuru entah macam mana tak terlalu besar berbanding entri pepenjuru yang sepadan
iaitu yang berada dalam baris yang sama dan yang berada dalam lajur yang sama dengan entri luar pepenjuru yang kita tengok tu
namun ada lebih banyak cerita di sebalik ini dan penting untuk kita tahu bahawa menjadi separa positif definitif adalah
sifat matriks secara keseluruhan dan bukan sekadar syarat pada entri individu jadi itulah contoh matriks
separa positif definitif dan kau boleh hasilkan contoh lain dengan mudah melalui kaedah yang serupa
sekarang jom kita tengok beberapa contoh matriks ketumpatan di mana selain daripada syarat separa positif definitif kita juga ada bahawa surih adalah
sama dengan satu berikut ialah beberapa contoh matriks ketumpatan 2x2 surih sama dengan
satu dalam keempat-empat kes dan kita juga boleh lihat bahawa ini adalah matriks Hermitian jadi menggunakan pencirian kedua
matriks separa positif definitif daripada tadi yang tinggal hanyalah menyemak bahawa nilai eigen semuanya bukan negatif
saya tinggalkan itu untuk kau semak jika kau mahu untuk matriks 2x2 ia tidak terlalu sukar untuk mengira nilai eigen secara manual
tetapi kau juga boleh minta komputer buat kau misalnya kau boleh gunakan fungsi eigen Val dalam pakej aljabar linear
untuk python kita juga boleh memperoleh matriks ketumpatan dengan hanya mengambil mana-mana matriks separa positif definitif bukan sifar
dan membahagikannya dengan surihannya misalnya berikut ialah matriks ketumpatan yang kita dapat dengan
membahagikan contoh yang kita lihat sebentar tadi dengan Surihannya membahagi dengan surih seperti ini
akan sentiasa mengekalkan sifat separa positif definitif dan kita pasti akan mendapat matriks yang mempunyai Surih sama dengan satu berdasarkan hakikat bahawa
surih adalah fungsi linear itulah koleksi kecil contoh dan kita akan lihat lebih banyak lagi semasa
pelajaran ini berlangsung seterusnya kita ambil beberapa minit untuk bincangkan tafsiran atau
makna intuitif matriks ketumpatan perkara pertama yang perlu diakui ialah mungkin nampak agak luar biasa
bahawa kita mewakili keadaan sistem dengan matriks dan bukannya vektor sebaliknya dalam formulasi ringkas
maklumat kuantum kita menggunakan vektor untuk mewakili keadaan sedangkan matriks khususnya matriks uniter
mewakili tindakan atau operasi ini memang cara matematik berfungsi dan walaupun kau boleh
sentiasa fikirkan matriks sebagai menerangkan pemetaan linear kita biasanya tidak mengaitkan makna intuitif langsung
kepada pemetaan linear yang dikaitkan dengan matriks ketumpatan tertentu walau bagaimanapun hakikat bahawa
matriks ketumpatan memang matriks ternyata merupakan aspek yang sangat penting dan kita akan lihat
itu semasa kita teruskan tetapi untuk sebutkan satu contoh buat masa ini nilai eigen bagi matriks ketumpatan tertentu
ternyata sangat penting kerana ia menerangkan berapa banyak Kerawakan atau ketidaktentuan yang wujud dalam keadaan
yang diterangkan oleh matriks ketumpatan itu cara lain untuk berfikir tentang matriks ketumpatan pada tahap intuitif
memberi tumpuan kepada entri matriks ini ingat bahawa baris dan Lajur matriks ketumpatan dipadankan
dengan keadaan klasik sistem yang kita bicarakan jadi untuk setiap entri kita ada satu
WEBVTT
keadaan klasik yang sepadan dengan baris entri itu dan satu keadaan klasik yang sepadan dengan lajur entri itu
untuk entri pepenjuru dua keadaan klasik itu adalah keadaan yang sama dan itulah sebabnya entri pepenjuru adalah
istimewa dan satu cara kita boleh tafsirkan entri pepenjuru ialah ia adalah kebarangkalian dan khususnya ia adalah
kebarangkalian bahawa keadaan klasik yang sepadan akan muncul jika kita melakukan pengukuran asas piawai
pada sistem yang keadaan kuantumnya kita huraikan untuk entri luar pepenjuru pula kita ada satu keadaan klasik yang sepadan dengan baris
entri itu dan keadaan klasik berbeza yang sepadan dengan lajur entri itu dan secara tidak formal
entri ini menerangkan tahap di mana dua keadaan klasik ini berada dalam superposisi kuantum serta
fasa relatif antara keduanya itu mungkin lebih masuk akal apabila pelajaran ini teruskan dan kita tengok lebih
dekat beberapa contoh spesifik dan butirannya mungkin tidak jelas pada ketika ini tetapi tolong jangan biarkan itu mengganggu kau
ini cukup tidak formal dan ia hanyalah idea intuitif untuk disimpan di belakang fikiran kau
seterusnya kita akan tengok perkaitan antara matriks ketumpatan dan vektor keadaan kuantum iaitu vektor lajur
yang mempunyai Norma Euclidean sama dengan satu sekadar mengingat kembali definisi matematik katakan kita ada
vektor keadaan kuantum psi yang mewakili keadaan sistem tertentu matriks ketumpatan yang mewakili
keadaan kuantum yang sama diberikan oleh ket psi kali bra psi seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini di skrin untuk jelaskan ini indeks psi
sepadan dalam beberapa cara dengan keadaan klasik sistem yang kita bicarakan dan itu akan menjadi tepat sama dengan padanan yang kita ada antara
baris dan Lajur matriks ketumpatan kita dengan keadaan klasik sistem jika kita bayangkan ada n
keadaan klasik sistem dan kita fikirkan vektor lajur dan baris sebagai matriks maka ket psi adalah matriks N kali satu
dan bra psi adalah matriks 1 kali n jadi apabila kita lakukan pendaraban kita dapat matriks N kali n
ini akan sentiasa menjadi matriks separa positif definitif hanya berdasarkan bentuknya dan ia juga akan mempunyai Surih sama dengan
satu berdasarkan hakikat bahawa psi adalah vektor unit dan kita akan lihat itu dengan lebih terperinci
tidak lama lagi keadaan kuantum yang diwakili oleh matriks ketumpatan berbentuk ini dipanggil keadaan tulen
berikut ialah beberapa contoh pertama jom kita pertimbangkan keadaan
ini di sini yang macam keadaan plus kecuali bahawa entri yang sepadan dengan keadaan klasik satu adalah
khayalan jika kita kira transpos konjugat kita akan dapat tanda tolak kerana konjugat kompleks i adalah
negatif i dan jika kita lakukan pendaraban kita akan dapat matriks yang ditunjukkan di sini di skrin ia adalah Hermitian seperti yang boleh kita
lihat serta merta dan ia kebetulan mempunyai satu nilai eigen sama dengan satu dan satu nilai eigen sama dengan
sifar jadi ia separa positif definitif dan Surihannya sama dengan satu jadi ia adalah matriks ketumpatan seperti yang
dijangkakan kita boleh kira matriks ketumpatan yang sepadan dengan asas piawai dan asas plus minus dengan cara yang serupa dan matriks ketumpatan itu
ditunjukkan di sini dan berikut ialah satu lagi contoh vektor keadaan kuantum ia kebetulan
muncul jauh di belakang dalam pelajaran pertama siri ini dan jika kita kira transpos konjugat kemudian darab
kita akan dapat matriks ketumpatan yang ditunjukkan di sini sekali lagi ia adalah Hermitian dan mempunyai
Surih sama dengan satu dan jika kau kira nilai eigen kau akan dapati ia sekali lagi mempunyai satu nilai eigen sama dengan satu dan satu
nilai eigen sama dengan sifar dan by the way itulah ciri biasa semua keadaan tulen ia sentiasa mempunyai satu nilai eigen
sama dengan satu dan baki nilai eigen semuanya sifar secara umum untuk vektor keadaan kuantum yang benar-benar sewenang-wenangnya
psi dengan sebarang bilangan entri jika kita darab ket psi dengan bra psi kita akan dapat
matriks ketumpatan yang kelihatan seperti ini perhatikan khususnya bahawa entri pepenjuru sentiasa salah satu
entri psi didarab dengan konjugat kompleks sendirinya yang boleh kita nyatakan secara alternatif sebagai nilai mutlak kuasa dua entri itu dan ini adalah
satu cara untuk melihat bahawa surih akan sentiasa sama dengan satu ia juga konsisten dengan catatan yang saya buat sebelum ini dalam pelajaran tentang
entri pepenjuru matriks ketumpatan yang memberitahu kita apakah kebarangkalian untuk melihat setiap keadaan klasik yang mungkin
jika kita melakukan pengukuran asas piawai dan satu catatan akhir di sana
tiada masalah mengenai fasa global untuk matriks ketumpatan dua keadaan kuantum adalah sama jika dan hanya jika matriks
ketumpatan mereka adalah sama khususnya katakan kita ada dua vektor keadaan kuantum psi dan fi yang
setara sehingga fasa global yang bermakna kita boleh nyatakan salah satu daripadanya fi katakanlah sebagai yang satu lagi kali
nombor kompleks pada bulatan unit jika kita kira perwakilan matriks ketumpatan fi maka apa yang akan
kita dapati ialah faktor fasa global didarabkan dengan konjugat kompleks sendirinya dan itu memberikan kita satu jadi ia
secara efektif hilang dan kita tinggal dengan matriks ketumpatan yang sama seperti yang kita dapat dari psi jadi itu agak
bagus dan secara lebih umum tiada masalah mengenai kesetaraan sehingga fasa global langsung apabila kita
bekerja dengan matriks ketumpatan itu pada dasarnya hanyalah kemerosotan yang wujud apabila kita menggunakan vektor keadaan kuantum berbanding
matriks ketumpatan untuk mewakili keadaan kuantum matriks ketumpatan memiliki sifat utama iaitu kombinasi cembung
matriks ketumpatan mewakili pilihan kebarangkalian atau rawak bagi keadaan kuantum
cara lain untuk mengatakannya ialah matriks ketumpatan boleh diratakan bersama dengan cara yang bermakna iaitu sesuatu yang
tidak boleh kita lakukan dengan vektor keadaan kuantum untuk menerangkan ini dengan lebih terperinci jom kita mulakan dengan situasi di mana
kita ada dua matriks ketumpatan rho dan sigma yang mewakili keadaan kuantum suatu sistem jom bayangkan
sistem itu disediakan dalam keadaan rho dengan kebarangkalian P untuk sesetengah pilihan P antara sifar dan satu dan jika tidak sistem itu
disediakan dalam keadaan Sigma misalnya mungkin p ialah setengah jadi kita
boleh bayangkan seseorang melambung duit syiling yang adil dan jika kepala mereka menjalankan suatu proses yang meninggalkan sistem dalam
keadaan rho dan jika tidak jika duit syiling menunjukkan ekor mereka menjalankan proses berbeza yang meninggalkan sistem dalam
keadaan Sigma soalannya sekarang ialah apakah keadaan sistem dan untuk jelaskan
kita berminat dengan keadaan sistem secara terpencil mengabaikan sebarang maklumat lain yang mungkin ada tentang
penyediaan mana yang dilakukan misalnya bayangkan kita tidak ada akses kepada duit syiling atau
ingatan sesiapa yang melakukan penyediaan keadaan dan jawapan kepada soalan itu ialah ia hanyalah purata berwajaran dua matriks
WEBVTT
ketumpatan iaitu P kali rho tambah 1 tolak P kali Sigma ini by the way adalah sepenuhnya
analog dengan apa yang kita ada jika rho dan sigma bukan matriks ketumpatan tetapi sebaliknya vektor kebarangkalian
yang mewakili keadaan kebarangkalian jadi ini bukan sesuatu yang mengejutkan atau misteri tetapi sebaliknya ia adalah sesuatu yang
mungkin biasa dari teori kebarangkalian kita selalu buat jenis pengambilan purata ini apabila kita mengira kebarangkalian dan berfikir
tentang pilihan rawak klasik dan intinya ialah ini juga berfungsi untuk matriks ketumpatan tetapi perhatikan bahawa ia tidak
berfungsi untuk vektor keadaan kuantum iaitu kau tidak boleh secara umum ratakan dua vektor keadaan kuantum
seperti ini dan berharap untuk mendapat vektor keadaan kuantum yang sah dan jika kau cuba kau biasanya akan mendapat vektor yang
tidak mempunyai Norma Euclidean sama dengan satu dengan matriks ketumpatan bagaimanapun purata berwajaran seperti ini akan sentiasa
menjadi matriks ketumpatan yang sah dan yang lebih penting matriks ketumpatan yang kau dapat akan mewakili pilihan rawak itu dengan cara yang
bermakna ini merangkumi pilihan rawak di mana ada lebih daripada dua
alternatif khususnya jika kita ada M matriks ketumpatan yang mungkin dan vektor kebarangkalian dengan M entri satu
untuk setiap matriks ketumpatan dan sistem disediakan dalam setiap keadaan yang mungkin dengan kebarangkalian yang sepadan
maka purata berwajaran matriks ketumpatan itu menerangkan keadaan sistem yang terhasil dan by the way apabila
kita merujuk kepada kombinasi cembung matriks ketumpatan inilah yang kita maksudkan kombinasi cembung hanyalah gabungan linear
di mana pekali membentuk vektor kebarangkalian ini akan sentiasa menjadi matriks
ketumpatan dan cara mudah dan ringkas untuk mengatakannya dalam istilah matematik ialah set semua matriks ketumpatan
yang sepadan dengan sistem tertentu adalah set cembung jadi jika kita ada katakanlah m vektor keadaan kuantum
psi 0 hingga psi M tolak satu bersama kebarangkalian p 0 hingga p m tolak satu yang secara kolektif membentuk
vektor kebarangkalian dan sistem disediakan dalam keadaan psi k dengan kebarangkalian pk untuk setiap k maka
keadaan sistem yang terhasil diterangkan oleh matriks ketumpatan yang ditunjukkan di sini di skrin khususnya kita tidak meratakan
vektor keadaan kuantum itu sendiri tetapi sebaliknya kita meratakan matriks ketumpatan yang sepadan
secara umum keadaan seperti ini tidak akan mempunyai perwakilan sebagai satu vektor keadaan kuantum
tunggal melainkan sesuatu yang remeh berlaku seperti semua vektor keadaan kuantum setara sehingga fasa global atau semua kecuali satu
kebarangkalian adalah sifar kita tidak akan mendapat keadaan kuantum tulen daripada proses seperti itu sebaliknya kita akan mendapat apa yang dipanggil
keadaan kuantum bercampur di mana ada ketidaktentuan yang wujud jom kita tengok contoh mudah
katakan kita ada qubit dan dengan kebarangkalian setengah qubit itu disediakan dalam keadaan sifar dan jika tidak
ia disediakan dalam keadaan plus berikut ialah matriks ketumpatan yang kita dapat dengan meratakan seperti yang telah
saya huraikan kita kira matriks ketumpatan yang sepadan dengan dua keadaan yang mungkin darab dengan kebarangkalian yang sepadan dan tambahkan
hasilnya apa yang kita dapat memang matriks ketumpatan ia adalah Hermitian Surihannya sama dengan satu
dan jika kau kira nilai eigen matriks ini kau akan dapat dua nombor nyata positif dan ia kebetulan adalah dua nombor yang mungkin sudah biasa kau dengar
sekarang iaitu kosinus kuasa dua pi dibahagi 8 dan sinus kuasa dua pi dibahagi 8 atau lebih kurang 0.85 dan
0.15 tiada perwakilan vektor keadaan kuantum tunggal bagi keadaan itu ia bukan keadaan tulen seterusnya kita akan tengok satu
matriks ketumpatan tertentu yang mewakili keadaan kuantum qubit tunggal yang dikenali sebagai keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya
keadaan ini muncul dengan kerap jadi elok kalau ada nama untuknya dan ia juga merupakan contoh yang baik kerana ia
menggambarkan ciri penting matriks ketumpatan sebenarnya ada keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya yang ditakrifkan secara analog untuk mana-mana
sistem tetapi buat masa ini kita akan fokus pada keadaan ini untuk qubit tunggal sahaja untuk kekalkan benda tetap
mudah katakan kita menetapkan keadaan qubit secara rawak sama ada keadaan sifar atau keadaan satu masing-masing dengan
kebarangkalian sama dengan setengah seperti bit rawak seragam kita boleh kira perwakilan matriks ketumpatan bagi
keadaan ini dengan cara biasa kita ambil purata dua perwakilan matriks ketumpatan bagi keadaan itu berikut ialah caranya
dalam bentuk matriks dan apa yang kita dapat ialah matriks identiti dibahagi dengan
dua keadaan ini dikenali sebagai keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya dan pada dasarnya ia mewakili ketidaktentuan yang lengkap atau maksimum
tentang qubit sama seperti vektor kebarangkalian seragam mewakili ketidaktentuan maksimum dalam
tatanan klasik kebarangkalian secara umum untuk sistem sewenang-wenang keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya adalah
keadaan yang kita dapat dengan memilih keadaan asas piawai secara seragam dan perwakilan matriks ketumpatan akan menjadi
matriks identiti dibahagi dimensi atau secara setara bilangan keadaan klasik sistem itu
pada ketika ini ini hanyalah terminologi tetapi jika kita ubah sedikit prosedur kita akan melihat ciri penting
matriks ketumpatan khususnya jom kita anggap bahawa kita mengubah prosedur dan dalam
tempat keadaan asas piawai sifar dan satu kita gantikan dengan keadaan plus dan minus kali ini kita mulakan dengan
ungkapan yang ditunjukkan di skrin tetapi jika kita lalui aritmetik kita dapat tepat sama
matriks ketumpatan ia adalah matriks identiti dibahagi dua jadi ia adalah keadaan yang sama seperti tadi iaitu
keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya ini seperti yang mereka kata adalah ciri dan bukan pepijat dua prosedur sebenarnya berbeza
tetapi jika yang kau ada hanyalah qubit yang terhasil tiada cara fizikal yang kau boleh membezakannya
walaupun secara statistik misalnya jika kau melakukan pengukuran asas piawai pada qubit ini
selepas prosedur pertama dilakukan kau sudah tentu akan mendapat hasil sifar dengan kebarangkalian setengah dan hasil satu dengan kebarangkalian setengah tetapi kau juga akan mendapat
tepat sama kebarangkalian hasil untuk prosedur kedua dan perkara yang sama berlaku untuk sebarang ujian lain yang mungkin kau
reka dengan syarat kau menguji qubit itu sahaja secara umum matriks ketumpatan tidak menerangkan bagaimana sistem itu
disediakan ia hanya memberitahu kau apa yang akan berlaku jika kau buat sesuatu pada sistem itu ke hadapan sama ada itu melakukan
operasi atau pengukuran dan sebenarnya matriks ketumpatan adalah sempurna dalam hal ini
jika dua alternatif berbeza menghasilkan matriks ketumpatan yang sama ia tidak dapat dibezakan walaupun
secara statistik tetapi jika dua matriks ketumpatan berbeza maka akan ada cara untuk membezakannya bukan
semestinya secara muktamad tetapi secara statistik apabila kita menggunakan formulasi umum kuantum
WEBVTT
maklumat klasik pada dasarnya muncul sebagai kes khas dan saya akan terangkan sekarang bagaimana itu
berfungsi khususnya kita akan lihat bagaimana keadaan kebarangkalian boleh diwakili oleh matriks
ketumpatan jom kita mulakan dengan keadaan klasik bermula dengan contoh mudah
berikut ialah perwakilan matriks ketumpatan bagi keadaan asas piawai sifar dan satu qubit
kita mengaitkan keadaan ini dengan keadaan klasik 0 dan satu dan jadi kita boleh fikirkan matriks ketumpatan ini sebagai
mewakili keadaan tersebut itu sangat mudah dan kita boleh mengeneralisasikan contoh dengan mudah
jika kita ada sistem yang set keadaan klasiknya adalah Sigma maka keadaan klasik a diwakili oleh atau
dikaitkan dengan matriks ketumpatan ket a bra a matriks itu mempunyai satu satu dalam entri pepenjuru
yang baris dan lajurnya sepadan dengan keadaan klasik a dan setiap entri lain adalah
sifar keadaan kebarangkalian diwakili oleh kombinasi cembung matriks berbentuk ini yang semulajadi
memandangkan apa yang kita tahu tentang matriks ketumpatan dan cara ia berfungsi khususnya bahawa kombinasi cembung matriks ketumpatan mewakili rawak atau
pilihan kebarangkalian keadaan kuantum misalnya jom katakan kita ada
sistem X yang set keadaan klasiknya merangkumi integer 0 hingga n tolak satu untuk sesetengah integer positif n
sudah tentu sedikit atau tiada keumuman yang hilang dengan mengandaikan bahawa set keadaan klasik kita mempunyai bentuk ini jika kita ada
set keadaan klasik yang berbeza kita boleh namakan semula keadaan klasik dengan cara ini dan ia selalu agak mudah untuk membuat andaian bahawa
set keadaan klasik kita kelihatan seperti ini sebahagian besar kerana itu memudahkan penulisan benda secara eksplisit dari segi
vektor dan matriks katakan kita ada keadaan kebarangkalian sistem X
yang diwakili oleh vektor kebarangkalian dengan cara biasa kita boleh mengaitkan keadaan kebarangkalian ini dengan matriks
ketumpatan seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin kita ambil purata berwajaran matriks ketumpatan yang sepadan dengan
keadaan klasik yang berbeza dan apa yang kita dapat ialah matriks ketumpatan pepenjuru khususnya kita lihat kebarangkalian
di sepanjang pepenjuru matriks ini dan setiap entri lain adalah sama dengan sifar tentu saja ini adalah matriks ketumpatan
kita memang jangkakan itu tetapi kita boleh juga sebabkannya secara langsung ia adalah matriks Hermitian Surihannya
sama dengan satu kerana kebarangkalian berjumlah satu dan dalam kes matriks pepenjuru nilai eigen adalah entri pepenjuru
dan semuanya bukan negatif kerana ia adalah kebarangkalian perhatikan juga bahawa setiap
matriks ketumpatan pepenjuru yang bermakna satu yang entri luar pepenjurunyasemua sifar mesti kelihatan seperti ini jadi ringkasnya
keadaan kebarangkalian boleh dikaitkan dengan matriks ketumpatan pepenjuru perhatikan by the way bahawa ini konsisten dengan
tafsiran tidak formal entri matriks ketumpatan yang saya sebut di awal pelajaran khususnya tiada apa yang berada dalam
superposisi kuantum di sini ini pada dasarnya hanyalah kerawakan klasik dan sewajarnya semua entri luar pepenjuru
adalah sifar lebih awal dalam siri ini kita membincangkan teorem spektral dan kita lakukan itu
khususnya untuk matriks uniter dalam konteks anggaran fasa teorem spektral adalah lebih
umum daripada itu namun bermakna ia memberitahu kita sesuatu tentang kelas matriks yang lebih luas bukan sekadar matriks uniter
dan khususnya ia terpakai kepada kelas matriks yang dipanggil matriks normal yang merangkumi semua matriks Hermitian serta
matriks uniter apa yang akan kita lakukan sekarang ialah melihat kenyataan berbeza teorem ini kali ini memberi tumpuan kepada sahaja
matriks separa positif definitif dan kemudian kita akan lihat bahawa ia memberitahu kita sesuatu yang sangat menarik dan penting tentang matriks
ketumpatan katakan P adalah mana-mana matriks separa positif definitif jadi itu termasuk mana-mana matriks ketumpatan serta mana-mana
matriks separa positif definitif yang kebetulan tidak mempunyai Surih sama dengan satu P adalah separa positif definitif jadi ia mesti
segiempat sama atau dalam erti kata lain N kali N untuk sesetengah pilihan N dan kita perlu merujuk nombor n itu jadi biar N menjadi
dipilih dengan sesuai atau cara lain untuk mengatakannya ialah anggap P adalah N kali N apa yang teorem ini beritahu kita dalam kes ini ialah
pasti wujud asas ortonormal vektor yang akan kita namakan psi 0 hingga psi N tolak satu bersama nombor nyata bukan negatif
Lambda 0 hingga Lambda N tolak satu sedemikian rupa P boleh dinyatakan seperti yang ditunjukkan
di sini di skrin dalam kata-kata jika kita darabkan setiap Lambda k dengan ket psi k kali bra psi k dan kemudian
jumlahkan ke atas semua k dari 0 hingga n tolak satu maka kita akan dapat P ini dipanggil penguraian
spektral P setiap Lambda k semestinya nilai eigen P dan setiap psi k adalah vektor eigen unit P
yang sepadan dengan nilai eigen itu jika kau tengok balik pelajaran 7 tentang anggaran fasa kau akan dapati teorem yang serupa
untuk matriks uniter di sana nilai eigennya adalah nombor kompleks pada bulatan unit dan bukannya nombor nyata bukan negatif
tetapi selainnya idea yang sama dan ini sebenarnya hanyalah dua kes khas teorem yang lebih umum yang dikenali sebagai
teorem spektral ia tidak berfungsi untuk setiap matriks kau perlu matriks itu bertukar dengan
transpos konjugat sendirinya dan itulah maksudnya matriks menjadi normal tetapi kita memang sentiasa ada
itu untuk matriks uniter dan matriks separa positif definitif dan untuk matriks Hermitian secara amnya di mana
kita sentiasa ada nilai eigen nyata tetapi tidak semestinya bukan negatif jadi itulah kenyataan
teorem spektral untuk matriks separa positif definitif sahaja dan sekarang jom kita lihat apa yang ia beritahu kita tentang matriks
ketumpatan apa yang ia beritahu kita ialah untuk matriks ketumpatan N kali N yang sewenang-wenang kita sentiasa boleh nyatakan matriks itu sebagai kombinasi cembung
N keadaan tulen dan tambahan pula kita boleh ambil N keadaan tulen itu untuk menjadi
ortogon itu mengikut secara langsung daripada teorem bersama fakta asas dari aljabar linear iaitu
jumlah nilai eigen mana-mana matriks sentiasa sama dengan surih matriks itu dalam erti kata lain apa yang kita benar-benar
lakukan di sini ialah menamakan semula nilai eigen p 0 hingga pN tolak satu dan kemudian memerhatikan bahawa apabila kita berbuat demikian dan
mengumpulkan nilai eigen itu ke dalam vektor n dimensi kita semestinya mendapat vektor kebarangkalian kerana semuanya mesti bukan negatif dan jumlahnya sama dengan
surih rho iaitu satu kerana rho adalah matriks ketumpatan jadi itu cukup mudah tetapi ia
sangat asas secara konsepsual apa yang ia beritahu kita ialah setiap matriks ketumpatan tidak
kira betapa rumitnya ia mungkin kelihatan boleh timbul dari memilih dahulu asas ortonormal sistem yang
kita bicarakan dan kemudian memilih secara rawak keadaan kuantum dari asas itu mengikut sesetengah pilihan untuk kebarangkalian
WEBVTT
kebarangkalian jika tidak jelas pada permukaannya kenapa itu menarik atau penting tak apa tetapi kita memang menggunakan
fakta ini dengan sangat kerap apabila kita berfikir tentang matriks ketumpatan dan sebenarnya menyatakan matriks ketumpatan tertentu
dengan cara ini sering kali merupakan perkara pertama yang kita lakukan apabila kita nak faham lebih lanjut
berikut ialah contohnya ingat matriks ketumpatan yang kita buat tadi di mana kita memilih secara rawak antara
keadaan sifar dan keadaan plus masing-masing dengan kebarangkalian setengah yang seperti yang kita kira mempunyai matriks ketumpatan yang
kelihatan seperti ini keadaan sifar dan keadaan plus tidak ortogon jadi ini bukan
penguraian spektral tetapi jika kita kira satu yang boleh kita lakukan dengan komputer atau secara manual dalam kes seperti ini maka apa yang
kita dapat ialah ungkapan matriks ketumpatan kita di mana nilai eigennya adalah nombor yang sentiasa muncul ini dan
di mana vektor eigen yang sepadan boleh dipilih seperti yang ditunjukkan di bawah di skrin dan sekali lagi kita dah pernah lihat vektor ini sebelumnya misalnya dalam
konteks permainan CHSH dalam Pelajaran Empat jadi itu menarik mengikut
ungkapan asal keadaan ini ialah yang kita dapat dengan memilih secara seragam antara dua keadaan iaitu keadaan sifar dan
keadaan plus tetapi sebenarnya kita mendapat tepat sama matriks ketumpatan dengan memilih secara rawak antara dua keadaan tulen
tetapi kita sangat sangat berat sebelah ke arah salah satu daripadanya lebih kurang 85% untuk yang pertama dan hanya lebih kurang 15% untuk
yang kedua jadi dalam erti tertentu sebenarnya ada jauh kurang kerawakan yang wujud pada keadaan itu berbanding yang mungkin
nampaknya pada mulanya ada cara geometri yang sangat bagus untuk berfikir tentang dan memvisualisasikan keadaan kuantum qubit tunggal yang dikenali
sebagai sfera Bloch ia hanya berfungsi untuk qubit tunggal untuk sistem yang mempunyai tiga
atau lebih keadaan klasik termasuk dua atau lebih qubit bersama ia tidak berfungsi lagi jadi ia cukup terhad tetapi
walaupun begitu ia cara yang hebat untuk berfikir tentang keadaan qubit tunggal ia boleh diperkenalkan jauh
di belakang dalam pelajaran pertama siri tentang sistem tunggal tetapi ia tidak benar-benar penting untuk memahami cara maklumat kuantum berfungsi dan ia juga mempunyai
perkaitan yang sangat bagus dengan matriks ketumpatan jadi ia secara semulajadi sesuai dalam pelajaran ini dan sebenarnya saya akan terangkan
ia dengan cara yang agak berbeza daripada cara yang mungkin paling biasa diterangkan dengan menggunakan matriks ketumpatan untuk secara efektif
menurunkannya jadi jika kau sudah biasa dengan sfera Bloch penjelasan ini mungkin sedikit berbeza daripada cara
kau pertama kali belajarnya tetapi pada akhirnya ia tentu saja harus setara kita akan mulakan dengan berfikir tentang
keadaan tulen yang mungkin bagi qubit pertama seperti yang diwakili oleh vektor keadaan kuantum
sehingga fasa global setiap vektor keadaan kuantum qubit boleh dinyatakan seperti
yang ditunjukkan di sini di skrin untuk tepatnya kita ada dua nombor nyata Theta dan fi dan kita akan
fikirkan dua nombor ini sebagai sudut yang dinyatakan dalam radian nombor pertama Theta adalah antara 0 dan pi atau secara setara ia adalah
sudut antara 0 dan 180 darjah dan nombor kedua fi adalah antara 0 dan 2 pi termasuk 0 tetapi bukan 2
pi jadi itu mana-mana sudut antara 0 dan 360 darjah entri Sifar vektor kita adalah
kosinus theta dibahagi 2 jadi itu nombor nyata antara 0 dan 1 dan khususnya ia semestinya bukan negatif
dan entri satu vektor kita adalah e kepada i kali fi kali sinus theta dibahagi 2 dan itu boleh jadi
mana-mana nombor kompleks pada atau di dalam bulatan unit kompleks ini sentiasa vektor unit atau
dalam erti kata lain ia adalah vektor keadaan kuantum yang sah dan untuk mana-mana vektor keadaan kuantum qubit yang diberi kita sentiasa boleh cari
vektor berbentuk ini yang setara dengan vektor itu sehingga fasa global khususnya kita sentiasa boleh
darab vektor yang diberi dengan fasa global untuk menjadikan entri Sifar nombor nyata bukan negatif pilih Theta yang
berfungsi untuk memberikan kita entri itu dan kemudian pilih fi untuk memadankan entri satu magnitud entri satu akan
sentiasa semestinya bersetuju dengan sinus theta dibahagi dua berdasarkan andaian bahawa kita mulakan dengan vektor
unit sekarang bukanlah persis benar bahawa Theta dan fi ditentukan secara unik oleh vektor keadaan kuantum yang kita mulakan
dengannya tetapi ia hampir-hampir begitu sentiasa akan ada nilai Theta unik antara sifar dan pi yang berfungsi
dan biasanya ada nilai fi unik yang berfungsi tetapi dalam dua kes khas itu tidak benar khususnya jika kita mulakan dengan
keadaan asas piawai maka Theta akan sama ada sifar atau pi dan dalam kedua-dua kes sebenarnya tidak kira apa fi ia adalah
sepenuhnya tidak relevan apabila Theta adalah sifar kosinus theta dibahagi 2 adalah 1 dan sinus theta dibahagi 2
adalah sifar jadi kita darab e kepada i kali fi dengan sifar jadi tidak ada bezanya apa fi adalah
dan jika Theta adalah pi maka kali ini kosinusnya adalah sifar dan sinusnya adalah satu jadi kita ada e kepada i kali fi kali ket 1 tetapi
vektor itu semua setara sehingga fasa global jadi sekali lagi tidak kira apa fi namun jika Theta terletak betul-betul
antara sifar dan pi maka sentiasa akan ada nilai fi unik yang berfungsi dan by the way kemerosotan yang mungkin
ini dalam nilai fi untuk dua kes khas itu akan masuk akal sepenuhnya apabila kita lihat gambar geometri dalam
sebentar lagi sekarang jom kita kira matriks ketumpatan yang dikaitkan dengan vektor keadaan berbentuk yang baru kita
kenal pasti jadi ini akan menjadi keadaan tulen qubit untuk melakukan ini kita darab vektor
dengan transpos konjugatnya seperti biasa dan di skrin ialah ungkapan matriks yang kita dapat dengan mengira transpos
konjugat dan melakukan pendaraban sekarang seperti setiap matriks 2x2
ada cara unik untuk mendapatkan matriks ini dengan mengambil gabungan linear matriks Pauli
termasuk matriks identiti khususnya kita boleh mendapatkan matriks ini dengan memilih pekali
matriks Pauli seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini di skrin kita letak dua di penyebut kerana itu akan
menjadikan semuanya berfungsi dengan baik tiada yang memaksa kita untuk berbuat demikian tetapi kita boleh dan ia akan membantu untuk berbuat demikian tetapi selain
daripada pilihan kosmetik ini tiada kebebasan di sini ini adalah satu-satunya cara untuk mendapatkan matriks ini dengan mengambil gabungan linear matriks Pauli itu
kerana matriks Pauli termasuk matriks identiti adalah asas untuk ruang vektor semua matriks 2x2 satu cara
untuk menyemak ketepatan ungkapan ini ialah menggunakan beberapa identiti trigonometri asas dan khususnya jika saya beralih untuk sebentar di sini
kita ada beberapa identiti yang akan menyelesaikan masalah jadi jika kau mahu jeda video atau
ambil tangkapan skrin dan lihat jika kau boleh mendapatkan ungkapan kedua matriks ketumpatan di bawah daripada yang pertama jadi ringkasnya mana-mana keadaan tulen
qubit yang dinyatakan sebagai matriks ketumpatan boleh ditulis sebagai gabungan linear matriks Pauli seperti yang ditunjukkan di
WEBVTT
skrin untuk Theta antara 0 dan pi dan fi antara 0 dan 2 pi perhatikan bahawa kita ada tepat sama
kemerosotan seperti sebelumnya iaitu fi tidak relevan apabila Theta sama ada sifar atau pi dan kali ini kita sebenarnya boleh
lihat itu dengan lebih jelas kerana sinus theta adalah sifar dalam dua kes itu dan selainnya tidak ada adalah worth pointing
out bahawa dalam formula ini kita ada Theta muncul sebagai argumen kepada fungsi sinus dan kosinus bukannya Theta dibahagi 2 seperti dalam vektor keadaan kuantum
versi asal dan itu kerana kita menggunakan identiti trigonometri itu tiga yang pertama pada dasarnya adalah
susun semula formula sudut berganda jadi sudutnya secara efektif digandakan dan sekarang kita akhirnya bersedia untuk
bincangkan sfera Bloch itu sendiri jom fokus pada tiga pekali matriks Pauli bukan identiti
dalam pengangka ungkapan matriks ketumpatan kita jadi kita mengabaikan dua dalam
penyebut kita juga mengabaikan matriks identiti kerana pekali itu tidak pernah berubah itu berlaku kerana
pekali itu ditentukan oleh surih matriks yang kita nyatakan dan matriks ketumpatan sentiasa mempunyai Surih sama dengan
satu sekarang bayangkan kita ada tiga paksi berlabel x y dan z yang diorientasikan mengikut
peraturan tangan kanan dan pertimbangkan titik yang koordinatnya sepadan dengan tiga pekali itu dan untuk jelaskan ini
adalah ruang tiga dimensi biasa yang kita bicarakan di mana koordinat sentiasa nombor nyata
koordinat x sepadan dengan pekali matriks Pauli sigma X dalam pengangka ungkapan kita yang sentiasa nombor nyata kerana matriks
ketumpatan adalah Hermitian dan begitu juga untuk Y dan Z apa yang kita dapati ialah titik yang
kita dapat sentiasa berada pada sfera unit atau dalam erti kata lain sfera yang mempunyai jejari sama dengan
satu dan khususnya ia adalah titik yang kita dapat jika kita mulakan dari titik di mana paksi z positif bersilang dengan sfera
yang boleh kita fikirkan sebagai Kutub Utara putar ke bawah ke arah paksi x positif dengan sudut theta dan kemudian
putar ke arah paksi y positif atau dalam erti kata lain ke Timur dengan sudut fi dalam konteks ini sudut Theta
dipanggil sudut kutub yang mudah diingat kerana ia bermula di kutub dan fi dipanggil sudut
azimut dan bersama dua sudut ini mewakili koordinat sfera untuk titik pada sfera unit dan jika
kau mahu kau boleh juga membenarkan jejari untuk berubah-ubah untuk mewakili titik sewenang-wenang dalam ruang tiga dimensi tetapi di sini kita memberi tumpuan kepada titik pada
sfera unit di mana jejarinya sama dengan satu kau juga boleh fikirkan Theta sebagai mewakili latitud kecuali kita pergi
dari 0 hingga 180 darjah dari Kutub Utara ke Kutub Selatan bukannya tambah tolak 90 darjah dari khatulistiwa dan fi mewakili
longitud di mana kita pada dasarnya takrifkan meridian perdana sebagai meridian yang bersilang dengan paksi x
positif jika kau macam saya by the way dan kau susah nak ingat yang mana satu latitud dan yang mana satu longitud mungkin membantu untuk ingat
bahawa longitud sepadan dengan selang yang lebih panjang 2 pi berbanding
pi anyway titik yang kita dapat pada sfera unit daripada vektor keadaan kuantum qubit kita psi dengan cara berfikir tentang koordinat ini
ialah perwakilan sfera Bloch bagi keadaan kuantum yang sepadan dengan psi dan apabila kita fikirkan keseluruhan
sfera tiga dimensi unit dengan cara ini kita mendapat sfera Bloch secara geometri ia hanyalah sfera unit
dalam ruang tiga dimensi biasa tetapi sebenarnya itulah geometri keadaan qubit
ada padanan satu-ke-satu yang sempurna di sini setiap keadaan tulen qubit sepadan dengan titik unik pada
sfera dan setiap titik pada sfera mewakili keadaan qubit unik sehingga fasa global apabila kita bekerja dengan
vektor keadaan kuantum padanan ini memang ada nama lain by the way ia kadang-kadang dipanggil sfera Poincare juga
misalnya tetapi dalam konteks maklumat kuantum ia biasanya dirujuk sebagai sfera Bloch perhatikan bahawa kita sekarang boleh lihat
kemerosotan dalam sudut fi dengan cukup jelas kerana longitud tidak bermakna di Kutub Utara dan Selatan tetapi selain
daripada kutub setiap titik di Bumi mempunyai koordinat unik dari segi latitud dan longitud dan perkara yang sama berlaku di sini jadi itulah cara
sfera Bloch berfungsi secara umum sekarang jom tengok beberapa contoh spesifik keadaan qubit dan
di mana ia terletak pada sfera Bloch jom mulakan dengan asas piawai ini adalah titik yang kita dapat
apabila sudut kutub Theta adalah sifar untuk keadaan sifar dan Pi untuk keadaan satu ini adalah dua kes di mana
sudut azimut fi tidak relevan seperti yang telah saya bincangkan kita juga boleh nyatakan matriks ketumpatan yang sepadan sebagai gabungan linear
matriks Pauli dengan cara mana-mana pun kita simpulkan bahawa dua keadaan ini sepadan dengan Kutub Utara dan
Kutub Selatan sfera Bloch keadaan sifar berada di atas dan keadaan satu berada di
bawah seterusnya jom cari keadaan plus dan minus pada sfera Bloch sekali lagi kita boleh sama ada fikirkan tentang
vektor keadaan kuantum atau matriks ketumpatan untuk vektor keadaan kuantum kali ini sudut kutub Theta mesti Pi
dibahagi 2 untuk mendapatkan entri Sifar menjadi 1 dibahagi akar 2 sudut azimut fi mesti sifar
untuk keadaan plus kerana entri satu adalah positif untuk keadaan plus dan ia mesti Pi atau 180 darjah untuk keadaan minus
kerana yang itu adalah negatif dalam kes itu jadi dua titik ini terletak pada
khatulistiwa sfera Bloch keadaan plus berada di mana paksi x positif bersilang dengan sfera dan keadaan minus berada di sisi bertentangan di mana
paksi x negatif bersilang dengan sfera secara setara kita juga boleh lihat dari ungkapan matriks Pauli untuk
matriks ketumpatan yang sepadan bahawa koordinat Y dan Z keduanya sifar sedangkan koordinat x adalah positif dan negatif
1 contoh lain ialah asas plus i minus i yang serupa dengan asas plus minus kecuali bahawa kita juga darab
entri satu dengan i unit khayalan kita dah lihat keadaan plus i sebelum ini dalam pelajaran dan keadaan minus i ditakrifkan
dengan cara yang analog sudut kutub Theta adalah sama dengan untuk keadaan plus dan minus iaitu Pi dibahagi
2 dan kali ini kita perlu pilih sudut azimut fi supaya kita dapat i dan negatif i bukannya 1 dan negatif 1
dan Pi dibahagi 2 dan 3 Pi dibahagi 2 adalah pilihan yang tepat untuk menjadikan itu berlaku sekali lagi kita juga boleh tengok
penerangan matriks ketumpatan keadaan ini dan semuanya agak serupa dengan dua contoh sebelumnya kecuali bahawa kali ini adalah matriks Pauli y berbanding
Z atau X jadi pada sfera Bloch dua keadaan ini terletak di mana paksi y
bersilang dengan sfera dan jika kita kemas sedikit kita boleh lihat dengan lebih jelas bagaimana enam keadaan yang baru kita bincangkan
berhubung antara satu sama lain untuk satu contoh lagi atau sebenarnya sekelas contoh pertimbangkan
vektor keadaan qubit yang muncul sebelum ini dan dalam Pelajaran Empat di mana entri Sifar adalah kosinus alpha untuk sesetengah nombor nyata Alpha dan entri satu
WEBVTT
adalah sinus alpha kita boleh by the way hadkan perhatian kita kepada nilai alpha antara sifar dan Pi kerana mana-mana
nilai alpha yang lain akan memberikan kita vektor yang setara sehingga fasa global kepada satu di mana Alpha berada dalam
julat ini jika kita kira matriks ketumpatan yang dikaitkan dengan keadaan ini yang dinyatakan sebagai gabungan linear matriks Pauli
kita mendapat ungkapan yang ditunjukkan di sini di skrin pengiraan itu tidak ditunjukkan di sini tetapi itulah yang kau patut
dapat jika kau lalui dan apa yang kita dapati ialah keadaan ini membentuk apa yang dipanggil bulatan besar yang melalui
kutub khususnya bermula dari Kutub Utara apabila Alpha adalah sifar turun meridian perdana dan
mencapai Kutub Selatan apabila Alpha adalah pi dibahagi 2 dan kemudian kembali ke Kutub Utara di sisi sfera yang bertentangan apabila Alpha berkisar dari pi dibahagi 2 ke
Pi dan itu semua masuk akal kerana nombor satu ini adalah vektor nyata jadi bahagian khayalan sentiasa sifar dan nombor
dua sudut Alpha secara efektif digandakan pada sfera Bloch dan sekali lagi itu boleh dijelaskan oleh penggunaan
formula sudut berganda kita dah lihat bahawa sfera Bloch menyediakan perwakilan geometri yang sangat bagus untuk keadaan tulen
qubit di mana setiap titik pada sfera sepadan dengan keadaan tulen qubit yang unik dan begitu juga sebaliknya
apabila kita merujuk kepada bola Bloch kita berbicara tentang semua titik pada sfera Bloch serta titik
yang terkandung di dalamnya titik pada bahagian dalam bola Bloch juga sepadan dengan keadaan qubit
khususnya keadaan yang bukan keadaan tulen jadi dalam erti kata lain ini adalah keadaan qubit yang boleh diwakili oleh matriks ketumpatan tetapi bukan oleh vektor keadaan qubit
aspek asas bola Bloch dan cara titik dalaman mewakili keadaan tidak tulen ialah
kombinasi cembung titik dalam bola Bloch sepadan dengan kombinasi cembung matriks ketumpatan
secara intuitif ini bermakna geometri terus berfungsi dengan sempurna walaupun di dalam bola
Bloch jom tengok beberapa contoh mulai dengan titik tengah bola Bloch yang mewakili
keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya diperolehi dengan meratakan keadaan sifar dan satu yang konsisten dengan hakikat
bahawa pusat sfera berada tepat di tengah-tengah antara Kutub Utara dan Kutub Selatan dan sebenarnya ia berada di tengah-tengah antara mana-mana dua titik antipodal seperti
keadaan plus dan minus serta keadaan plus i dan minus i titik antipodal dalam sfera Bloch sentiasa sepadan dengan
keadaan tulen yang ortogon dan apa ini mendedahkan atau mencerminkan ialah kita sentiasa boleh tulis keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya
sebagai purata antara mana-mana dua keadaan tulen qubit yang ortogon cara lain untuk melihat ini ialah
fikirkan tentang perwakilan matriks Pauli bagi keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya untuk menjadikan ini berfungsi kita mesti tetapkan
pekali pada semua tiga matriks Pauli bukan identiti kepada sifar dan jadi titik yang sepadan di dalam
bola Bloch berada tepat di tengah pada titik asal dan by the way berfikir tentang perwakilan matriks Pauli matriks
ketumpatan seperti ini sebenarnya menjadikannya cukup jelas bahawa kombinasi cembung titik bola Bloch sepadan dengan kombinasi cembung
matriks ketumpatan jika kita ambil purata atau purata berwajaran matriks ketumpatan dan
nyatakan semuanya dari segi gabungan linear matriks Pauli maka sudah tentu kita hanya meratakan titik yang sepadan kerana segalanya
adalah linear dalam tiga pekali itu untuk satu contoh lagi jom pertimbangkan purata keadaan sifar
dan keadaan plus yang kita lihat sebelum ini dalam pelajaran kita kira perwakilan matriks ketumpatan yang ditunjukkan pada
skrin dan kita ada bahawa titik berada di bahagian dalam bola Bloch di tengah-tengah antara keadaan sifar dan plus
kita juga melihat bahawa kita boleh nyatakan matriks ketumpatan ini dengan cara berbeza berdasarkan penguraian spektralnya dan
sekali lagi itu konsisten dengan gambar rajah dan contoh-contoh sebelumnya dan itu menyimpulkan
perbincangan tentang sfera Bloch dan bola Bloch orang selalu bertanya sama ada ada sfera Bloch atau bola Bloch untuk sistem yang mempunyai
tiga atau lebih keadaan klasik dan jawapan yang malangnya ialah tidak begitu kita sentiasa boleh fikirkan tentang
keadaan kuantum sistem dalam istilah geometri serupa dengan bola Bloch dan kita akan mendapat badan cembung dalam ruang vektor nyata
tetapi jika kita ada tiga atau lebih keadaan klasik ia tidak akan berbentuk sfera misalnya jika kita ada
tepat tiga keadaan klasik atau qutrit secara ringkas kita akan mendapat badan cembung dalam ruang lapan dimensi
tetapi titik ekstrem badan itu yang sepadan dengan keadaan kuantum tulen qutrit hanya akan bersifat
empat dimensi jika kau boleh bayangkan mengambil manifold empat dimensi dalam ruang lapan dimensi dan entah macam mana mengecut lapnya untuk mendapatkan badan cembung
dan kau mendapati itu cara yang berguna untuk berfikir tentang qutrit maka lebih baik untuk kau saya rasa itu menarik untuk
difikirkan tetapi ia bukan bola ia lebih rumit daripada itu dalam bahagian akhir pelajaran kita akan membincangkan secara ringkas
cara matriks ketumpatan berfungsi untuk pelbagai sistem matriks ketumpatan boleh mewakili keadaan pelbagai sistem dan ini
berfungsi dengan cara yang sepenuhnya analog dengan faktor keadaan kuantum khususnya seperti yang kita ada dalam formulasi ringkas maklumat kuantum
kita boleh lihat pelbagai sistem bersama seolah-olah ia adalah sistem majmuk tunggal
kali ini baris dan Lajur matriks ketumpatan yang mewakili keadaan pelbagai sistem diletakkan
dalam padanan dengan hasil darab Cartesian set keadaan klasik sistem individu misalnya kita boleh pertimbangkan
perwakilan matriks ketumpatan bagi empat keadaan Bell yang kita dapat tepat seperti yang kita lakukan untuk vektor keadaan kuantum
lain sebelum ini dalam pelajaran dengan mendarabkan vektor keadaan dengan transpos konjugatnya dan hasilnya ditunjukkan di sini di
skrin pada dasarnya tiada yang baru pada tahap konsepsual walaupun kita akan lihat sebentar lagi bahawa ada beberapa
perkara baru yang boleh kita lakukan dengan matriks ketumpatan untuk pelbagai sistem Konsep Kebebasan dan
korelasi dilanjutkan dari vektor keadaan kuantum kepada matriks ketumpatan dan khususnya kita dapati bahawa hasil darab tensor
matriks ketumpatan mewakili Kebebasan antara sistem kita menggunakan terminologi yang sama yang
kita gunakan untuk vektor keadaan kuantum misalnya jika kita ada sistem X yang disediakan dalam keadaan rho dan sistem y
yang disediakan secara bebas dalam keadaan Sigma maka keadaan pasangan XY bersama diberikan oleh hasil darab tensor
rho dan sigma kita panggil ini keadaan hasil dan ini merangkumi secara semulajadi kepada lebih daripada dua
sistem matriks ketumpatan yang tidak boleh dinyatakan sebagai keadaan hasil mewakili korelasi antara sistem dan
bahagian itu serupa dengan vektor keadaan kuantum tetapi rupa-rupanya ada jenis korelasi berbeza yang boleh timbul apabila kita menggunakan matriks ketumpatan walaupun untuk
hanya dua sistem sebaliknya sebenarnya hanya ada satu jenis korelasi yang boleh kita ada untuk vektor keadaan kuantum dan
itulah keterbelitan untuk mengatakannya dengan cara lain korelasi dan keterbelitan adalah sinonim untuk vektor keadaan kuantum tetapi
WEBVTT
itu tidak benar untuk matriks ketumpatan di sini benda lebih menarik misalnya kita boleh menerangkan
keadaan klasik berkorelasi dengan matriks ketumpatan berikut ialah contoh matriks ketumpatan yang mewakili bit rawak klasik
yang dikongsi antara Alice dan Bob mereka selalu mempunyai keadaan klasik yang sama sifar atau satu dan kebarangkalian adalah
setengah untuk setiap kemungkinan ini bukan keadaan terbelit keterbelitan bersifat bukan klasik tetapi
ia adalah keadaan berkorelasi contoh lain berkait dengan konsep ensemble keadaan kuantum
yang boleh kau fikirkan sebagai taburan kebarangkalian ke atas set terhingga keadaan kuantum khususnya jom bayangkan
kita ada M matriks ketumpatan rho sifar hingga rho M tolak satu yang semuanya mewakili keadaan yang mungkin bagi sistem tertentu
berserta kebarangkalian untuk menarik setiap satu jika kita mahu kita boleh kira purata berwajaran matriks ketumpatan ini
dengan mengambil kombinasi cembung mereka tetapi itu sebenarnya tidak akan memberitahu kita apakah keadaan individu atau apakah
kebarangkaliannya apa yang boleh kita lakukan sebaliknya dan ia agak berguna untuk melakukan ini kadang-kadang ialah pertimbangkan matriks
ketumpatan berbentuk yang ditunjukkan di sini di skrin ini adalah keadaan dua sistem di mana sistem pertama mempunyai satu keadaan klasik
untuk setiap alternatif dan kita ambil purata berwajaran M keadaan hasil di mana keadaan sistem pertama
sentiasa klasik dan pada dasarnya melabel mana daripada m keadaan yang kita ada untuk sistem kedua
jika tidak jelas tepat mengapa kita nak fikirkan tentang keadaan seperti ini tak apa ia hanyalah contoh
jenis korelasi di mana sistem pertama sentiasa klasik dan sistem kedua boleh berada dalam keadaan kuantum
kategori ketiga keadaan yang mungkin berkorelasi ialah set keadaan yang dipanggil keadaan
boleh pisah dalam istilah mudah ini adalah kombinasi cembung keadaan hasil dan ia pada dasarnya mewakili keadaan kuantum
di mana mana-mana korelasi antara sistem adalah korelasi klasik satu cara untuk fikirkan tentang
keadaan seperti ini ialah kita membuat pilihan kebarangkalian untuk nombor K dan kemudian secara bebas sediakan dua
sistem dalam keadaan kuantum yang boleh bergantung pada pilihan K ini apa yang mungkin paling menarik tentang
keadaan berbentuk ini ialah inilah cara kita sebenarnya takrifkan keterbelitan dalam istilah matematik khususnya keterbelitan
ditakrifkan sebagai kekurangan kebolehpisahan jadi jika kau ada matriks ketumpatan dan tidak mungkin untuk menyatakannya dalam bentuk
seperti ini maka dengan definisi ia terbelit saya menyinggung ini balik dalam Pelajaran Empat dan di sini ia dalam
perincian yang lebih besar by the way boleh jadi sangat sukar untuk mengetahui sama ada matriks ketumpatan tertentu mewakili
keadaan terbelit walaupun dengan bantuan komputer secara matematik dan pengiraan keterbelitan
sebenarnya agak rumit saya sebutkan di awal pelajaran bahawa ada perkara yang sangat penting yang boleh kita lakukan dengan matriks ketumpatan dan
ia adalah untuk menerangkan keadaan bahagian terpencil sistem walaupun apabila ia berkorelasi dan mungkin terbelit dengan sistem lain
istilah keadaan terkurang sering digunakan dalam konteks ini dan sebagai contoh mudah kita akan kira keadaan terkurang
bagi qubit individu yang membentuk ebit untuk tepatnya jom katakan bahawa
Alice dan Bob berkongsi ebit Alice memegang qubit a Bob memegang qubit B dan bersama dua qubit ini berada dalam keadaan fi
plus dan soalannya yang akan kita jawab ialah apakah keadaan qubit Alice a dalam
pengasingan sudah tentu kita boleh tanya soalan yang sama untuk qubit Bob tetapi mudah untuk menjawab soalan itu apabila kita tahu jawapan soalan ini
sekarang mungkin menggoda untuk mengatakan bahawa kita tidak dapat menerangkan keadaan qubit Alice secara terpencil kerana ia
terbelit dengan qubit Bob yang mungkin entah macam mana menghalang kita dari menerangkan atau bahkan memikirkan tentang keadaan a dalam
pengasingan tetapi ini adalah salah memang benar bahawa kita tidak dapat menerangkan keadaan a dengan vektor keadaan kuantum
kerana seperti yang akan kita lihat ia bukan dalam keadaan tulen tetapi setiap sistem mempunyai keadaan pada bila-bila masa yang boleh
diterangkan oleh matriks ketumpatan sama ada ia terbelit dengan sistem lain atau tidak sebagai eksperimen minda hanya untuk membantu
kita melihat apakah jawapan kepada soalan ini jom katakan Bob memutuskan untuk mengambil qubitnya dan pergi ke bintang-bintang dan dia tidak pernah didengari lagi
tetapi bayangkan bahawa di suatu tempat dalam perjalanannya dia memutuskan untuk melakukan pengukuran asas piawai pada
qubitnya baik kita tahu cara mengira kebarangkalian bagi dia mendapat dua hasil yang mungkin dan kita juga tahu apakah
keadaan a akan menjadi untuk setiap hasil yang mungkin dan perkara itu diringkaskan dalam jadual ini khususnya dengan kebarangkalian setengah
a akan tinggal dalam keadaan sifar dan dengan kebarangkalian setengah a akan tinggal dalam keadaan satu dan jadi seperti yang dibincangkan sebelum ini dalam
pelajaran ini ia meninggalkan a dalam keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya dan oleh itu itulah jawapannya
kepada soalan kita sekarang kau mungkin membantah dan mengatakan bahawa ini bergantung pada hakikat bahawa
Bob memutuskan untuk mengukur qubitnya dan andaian bahawa dia melakukan ini adalah sebahagian daripada cerita yang membawa kita kepada jawapan ini tetapi
jika Bob berada bertahun cahaya jauhnya pada masa dia mengukur tiada yang dia lakukan boleh memberi pengaruh apa pun pada mana-mana
eksperimen yang mungkin Alice putuskan untuk lakukan pada qubitnya jika tidak kita akan ada komunikasi lebih laju dari cahaya
jadi qubit Alice berada dalam keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya tanpa mengira sama ada Bob mengukur atau tidak
saya harus jelaskan pada ketika ini bahawa konsep keadaan terkurang dan cara ia ditakrifkan tidak benar-benar bergantung pada relativiti
atau ketidakmungkinan komunikasi lebih laju dari cahaya ini hanyalah cara untuk menerangkannya dalam istilah yang diharap intuitif
pada hakikatnya ada definisi matematik yang akan kita lihat dalam konteks yang lebih umum dalam sebentar lagi ia konsisten dengan jawapan ini
dan kebetulannya dengan ketidakmungkinan komunikasi lebih laju dari cahaya dan juga tiada definisi lain yang boleh konsisten dengan maklumat kuantum seperti yang kita ketahui
sekarang jom pertimbangkan keadaan terkurang dalam keumuman yang lebih besar katakan kita ada pasangan sistem A dan B bukan semestinya qubit yang bersama dalam keadaan tulen
yang diwakili oleh vektor keadaan kuantum psi sekali lagi kita akan fokus pada keadaan terkurang sistem a dan untuk
melakukan ini ia akan membantu untuk berfikir tentang keadaan klasik sistem B jadi jom biar gamma menjadi set ini
keadaan klasik b seperti yang telah kita bincangkan sebelumnya dalam pelajaran dua siri misalnya
ada koleksi unik vektor fi b untuk setiap b dalam Gamma yang ungkapan psi yang ditunjukkan di skrin
adalah betul dan khususnya ada formula mudah untuk vektor ini kita hanya darab vektor psi dengan
hasil darab tensor matriks identiti yang sepadan dengan sistem a dengan bra b untuk b yang kita minati
apa yang kita lakukan di sini pada dasarnya ialah menyediakan diri kita untuk mengira apa yang akan berlaku jika kita melakukan pengukuran asas piawai
WEBVTT
asas piawai pada B dan sekali lagi ini telah diliputi dalam pelajaran dua siri
katakan kita memang melakukan pengukuran asas piawai pada B setiap hasil yang mungkin kemudiannya akan
muncul dengan kebarangkalian sama dengan norma Euclidean kuasa dua vektor fi b yang sepadan dan bersyarat pada mendapat
hasil tertentu b kita menormalkan vektor fi B untuk menentukan keadaan a yang terhasil
mengikut penaakulan yang sama seperti dalam contoh ebit dari sebentar tadi kita mendapat ungkapan yang ditunjukkan di
skrin untuk keadaan terkurang a sebagai matriks ketumpatan dan by the way norma kuasa dua dalam penyebut datang dari
darab vektor yang dinormalkan dengan transpos konjugatnya jadi kita mendapat norma Euclidean dua kali dalam
penyebut norma Euclidean kuasa dua membatalkan dan kita tinggal dengan ungkapan yang cukup mudah
dan sebenarnya jika kita gantikan formula kita untuk fi B yang berfungsi untuk setiap B kita mendapat formula untuk keadaan terkurang
sistem a dari segi penerangan matriks ketumpatan keadaan tulen yang kita mulakan dengannya iaitu ket psi
bra psi jadi inilah formula kita untuk keadaan terkurang sistem a dengan syarat sistem majmuk AB bermula dalam
keadaan tulen psi tetapi kita juga boleh gunakan formula itu dengan lebih umum khususnya jom katakan
keadaan ab diberikan oleh matriks ketumpatan rho yang boleh mengambil bentuk ket psi bra psi untuk sesetengah vektor keadaan kuantum
psi tetapi tidak semestinya ia mengikut pada dasarnya oleh kelinearan bahawa keadaan terkurang a
ditentukan oleh formula yang sama seperti yang kita ada untuk keadaan tulen kecuali kita gantikan matriks ketumpatan rho yang mana saja yang kita
inginkan sebagai notasi ringkas ia agak biasa bahawa kita nyatakan keadaan terkurang ini dengan nama yang kita gunakan untuk
matriks ketumpatan rho dalam kes ini tetapi kita letak subskrip yang menunjukkan sistem yang kita fokuskan jadi rho dengan
subskrip a bermakna keadaan terkurang a apabila sistem majmuk berada dalam keadaan rho superskrip juga kadang-kadang digunakan
sebagai ganti subskrip ia pada dasarnya hanyalah pilihan peribadi dan ia bermakna perkara yang sama
kita telah fokus pada sistem a sahaja untuk kesederhanaan tetapi kita juga boleh mendapatkan keadaan terkurang sistem B
secara analog tetapi di mana formula diadaptasikan dengan cara yang semulajadi segalanya simetri di sini kita
pada dasarnya hanya menukar peranan A dan B dan khususnya jumlah berkisar ke atas keadaan klasik a kali ini
bukannya b dan dalam formula di skrin kita mengandaikan set keadaan klasik a dipanggil
Sigma semua ini merangkumi dengan cara yang cukup mudah kepada tiga atau lebih sistem misalnya jika kita ada tiga
sistem a b dan c yang secara kolektif berada dalam keadaan yang diterangkan oleh matriks ketumpatan rho maka kita boleh mendapatkan
keadaan terkurang pasangan a bersama dengan formula yang ditunjukkan di sini serta keadaan sistem ketiga sahaja
yang merupakan formula kedua dan kau boleh pertimbangkan kombinasi lain dan merangkumnya kepada seberapa banyak sistem yang kau mahukan jumlah sentiasa diambil ke atas
set keadaan klasik sistem yang diabaikan dan coraknya sentiasa sama dengan matriks
ketumpatan yang kita mulakan dengannya terletak di antara hasil darab tensor matriks identiti dan bra serta ket yang sepadan dengan asas piawai
untuk menyimpulkan pelajaran ini saya akan katakan sedikit lagi tentang definisi yang baru kita liputi operasi pada matriks
ketumpatan yang menerangkan keadaan terkurang mempunyai nama dan ia dipanggil surih separa untuk dua sistem A dan B surih
separa ke atas B dan surih separa ke atas a seperti yang ditakrifkan di sini di skrin ini adalah tepat sama
formula yang kita lihat sebentar tadi dan sekarang kita hanya memikirkannya sebagai fungsi rho dan memberikannya
nama nama kelihatan seperti surih kecuali bahawa ada subskrip yang memberitahu kita sistem mana yang sedang dikeluarkan
atau dalam erti kata lain sistem mana yang set keadaan klasiknya kita jumlahkan ke atas dan yang terletak di antara bra dan
ket apabila kita mengambil surih separa bagi B misalnya yang diterangkan oleh Formula pertama kita kadang-kadang kata
b disurihi keluar dan begitu juga untuk a secara intuitif mesurihi keluar sistem
hanya bermakna kita buang atau abaikan sahaja itulah satu cara untuk takrifkan surih
separa dan cara setara lain ialah kata bahawa pemetaan ini adalah pemetaan linear unik yang memenuhi
formula yang ditunjukkan di sini di sebelah kanan khususnya jika kita ada hasil darab tensor dua matriks M dan N katakanlah
dan kita lakukan surih separa ke atas sistem pertama maka apa yang kita dapat ialah surih matriks pertama M kali
matriks kedua dan syaratnya simetri apabila kita surihi sistem kedua bukan setiap matriks yang kita akan
kira surih separanya adalah hasil darab tensor seperti ini tetapi setiap matriks boleh dinyatakan sebagai gabungan linear
hasil darab tensor dan kita boleh menentukan surih separa dari syarat ini berserta hakikat bahawa ini adalah fungsi
linear dan itulah sebabnya ia dipanggil surih separa definisi setara ini boleh
sangat membantu kerana kita sering kali boleh gunakannya berbanding formula asal berikut ialah contoh yang
menggambarkan ini katakan kita ada pasangan qubit a dalam keadaan yang matriks ketumupatannya ditunjukkan di sini di
skrin ini kebetulan merupakan contoh keadaan berkorelasi di mana a sama ada dalam keadaan sifar atau keadaan satu masing-masing
dengan kebarangkalian setengah jadi kita boleh fikirkan a sebagai klasik jika a dalam keadaan sifar maka
begitu juga B dan jika a dalam keadaan satu maka B dalam keadaan plus jika kita nak tahu apakah keadaan terkurang a
kita surihi B keluar dan jika kita gunakan formula kedua dari definisi setara berserta kelinearan maka kita boleh
WEBVTT
kira ini dengan agak mudah khususnya surih ket 0 bra 0 adalah satu begitu juga surih ket plus bra
plus jadi faktor tensor itu hilang dan kita tinggal dengan keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya dalam garis yang sama kita boleh kira
keadaan terkurang B dengan mesurihi a keluar kali ini faktor tensor pertama yang kita lakukan surih ke atasnya jadi
kita menggunakan Formula pertama dari definisi setara dan kita tinggal dengan setengah kali ket 0 bra 0 tambah setengah kali ket
plus bra Plus atau dalam erti kata lain matriks ketumpatan yang sama yang muncul beberapa kali sebelumnya kau akan mendapat tepat sama
keputusan jika kau gunakan formula dari definisi pertama tetapi ini adalah cara yang jauh lebih mudah untuk melakukannya ini semua merangkumi kepada tiga atau lebih
sistem tetapi untuk video ini saya akan berhenti di sini dan tinggalkan ini untuk kau pertimbangkan sendiri dan itulah sahaja untuk pelajaran ini yang
memperkenalkan matriks ketumpatan dan menerangkan asas cara ia berfungsi kita juga membincangkan sfera Bloch
serta jenis korelasi yang berbeza dan konsep keadaan terkurang sistem saya harap kau akan sertai saya untuk
pelajaran seterusnya yang berkaitan dengan saluran iaitu pemetaan linear dari matriks ketumpatan kepada matriks ketumpatan yang
menerangkan operasi pada sistem selamat tinggal sehingga
jumpa lagi